my name is Sean and I support the
engineering team up into landl prior to
joining Bento NL I I lead the teams in
service infrastructure art and Linkedin
I'm back at LinkedIn we build service
Frameworks that power linkedin's service
oriented architecture the goal was to
develop service Frameworks to build a
provide a right level of abstraction and
standardization across the company
it is also from there that I learned the
value of good Frameworks and deliver to
engineering teams so they can focus on
building applications without having to
worry about the infrastructure
underneath and that is the role that I
see been to learn now can play to help
data science and machine learning teams
around the world
my journey to join inventory now is a
little bit unconventional I spend a year
working with a team on the open source
side before joining full-time this
summer so in the hindsight I think this
is a very rewarding experience for me to
get to know the team and the project
very deeply before joining full-time
so into my mouth is a open source
framework we created for uh and now
serving and development at deployment it
has been adopted by hundreds of
organizations around the world across
different Industries today I'll talk to
you
um about the considerations and
learnings that went into building rental
and now
so first the problem as a data scientist
once you have a trained model and you
want to allow other people and
applications to have access to your
trained model because after all that is
how you can realize the impact the most
common pattern to do this is to serve
the model behind an API endpoint what
are the solutions out there for serving
in the following analysis we will group
the solution into two categories and
evaluate them across two Dimensions the
ease of use and flexibility
ease of use is important because it
allows you to build a solution without
spending a ton of engineering efforts
and have short time to Market
flexibility is important because it will
allow the solution to grow and scale as
your use case expects so teams won't
have to adopt a whole new solution for
the next ml project
foreign
the first group let's call them an
off-the-shelf Solutions there are many
off-the-shelf solutions you can choose
from depending on what framework to
train your model in if the model was
trained in tensorflow you can consider
using tensorflow serving if the model
was trained in a pie torch you can
consider using torch serve you can also
use a more generic framework like the
Triton inference server which supports
multiple ml Frameworks such as Onyx
tensorflow torch script to use these
Frameworks is relatively simple you only
need to provide a model that you want to
serve along with a set of configurations
indicating how you like to run the
models and these Frameworks comes with a
pre-built server binaries and Docker
container images that you can just use
out of the box and the input and output
types are typically tensors
these Frameworks are great for low
latency serving because they run models
are specialized runtime that are highly
optimized for performance because the
runtime is specialized they can usually
utilize underlying Hardware very
efficiently
however there are these Solutions are
not very easy to customize first they
are written in different languages and
Frameworks you should develop model
using multiple ml Frameworks you'll have
to work with different solutions you
will have to develop other services to
call these models to fulfill the entire
use case
the model inference rules of these
Solutions are defined in a declarative
way through configurations yamos yamos
are simple but they could complicate
development not only do users still have
to learn all the different settings
available to the yaml they cannot
iterate and test very easily
second
model inference is really just a small
part of ml Services these Solutions do
not offer a very straightforward way to
define custom logic like pre and
post-processing data validation feature
transformation Etc and input and output
types are also just often limited to
tensors other types such as tabular
forms Json audio video image files are
also very common for ML services use
cases and these input and output types
are now very well supported
lastly many use cases require inference
on multiple models multi-model
inferences when you have an ensemble of
models working together in parallel or
in sequence to form an inference result
together
in this credit application example which
we'll look at again later in this talk
we first want to detect if an
application is a fraud only if the
application is genuine do we pass the
application to the risk assessment
models in parallel and gather the result
back together to make a final decision
most of these off-the-shelf Solutions
support inference only on a single model
even for the Frameworks that do support
multi-model inference we still have a
problem because we will have to scale
all the models together as opposed to
being able to scale them independently
because they belong in the same
container
so off-the-shelf Solutions are easy to
use offer low development costs and high
serving efficiency but they are not
flexible when it comes to supporting the
different Frameworks defining custom
Logics and scaling model scaling options
foreign
us to the second group of solutions what
I call the in-house DIYs this group
consists of generic Frameworks such as
fast API golang and grpc that help you
build your ml service from scratch you
can Define your custom business logic
freely because these are generic
Frameworks that you can practically
build anything with
the most straightforward option is to
package the different models together in
the service and you can invoke the
models and custom Logics however you
like
the challenge with this approach is that
we force to co-deploy models and run the
same runtime run in the same runtime or
Hardware which may not be the most
optimal for running them for example for
Io intensive pre and post processing
logic it may be ideal to run on
instances with a lot of memory however
for compute intensive model inference
logic it may be best to run on a GPU or
multi-core CPU instance coupling all of
these together means that the instance
will have to satisfy both i o and
compute intensity requirements which may
end up to be quite expensive
alternatively we can separate the models
and inference custom Logics as different
distributed microservices allowing them
to run on the most optimal hardware and
scale independently
while powerful microservices are still
very difficult to develop and operate
due to the added complexity of RPC
service mesh observability and CI CD
most importantly the skill set required
to run microservices misaligned with
most data science teams today many data
science job descriptions have kubernetes
at the scale requirements because data
scientists ultimately have to bring
models to production
regardless of which service architecture
that you choose the uh to build and
deploy end-to-end you will have to work
with containerization tools like Docker
and the deployment orchestration system
like kubernetes so the challenge of
so the challenge of using these
Frameworks is that building annual
service from scratch is still quite hard
and expensive the skill set required is
also not core to many data science and
animal engineering teams while flexible
this group of solution has high
engineering costs a long term long time
to mock Market which makes them
practically unaffordable to most teams
foreign
discussed the previous two groups of
solutions let's explore what an ideal
solution should look like that is you
know both easy to use and flexible
first the solution should be flexible
for defining custom logic and
multi-model inference graphs instead of
declaratively using yamls we want to do
imperatively with maybe python we you
probably already know declarative
programming is a paradigm for defining
what the program does where imperative
programming is a paradigm that
describing how the program does it by
giving it a step-by-step instructions
imperative programming is more natural
when it comes to defining the very
flexible business logic and on top of
that the intention of yaml is to
simplify business logic definition
without asking the user to learn a whole
new programming language but oftentimes
yaml fails to do that on the other hand
python is already a very common
programming language skill among the
data scientist user group and has great
community support for Amna libraries and
data science use cases
so instead of defining the inference
logic declaratively using yaml we think
is more advantageous to do so with
imperatively using python
second we want the different workloads
to run on the most optimal runtime and
Hardware profiles this time not only do
we have the compute intensive model
inference logic that that's right on GPU
and multi-core CPUs we also have
potentially i o intensive logic such as
pre-processing feature transformation or
calling a database or Downstream API on
top of that these workloads should be
able to scale independently and
automatically based on the resource
utilization of the workloads
third we want the develop deployment of
the most uh to be in the most optimal
format for the Target environment based
on the use case
for simpler use cases I may want to
serve my model as a container in a
serverless environment but for teams
that manage their own clusters I may
want to deploy and serve a model from a
kubernetes cluster regardless of where
the models are deployed users should not
have to rewrite their service just to
deploy to a different environment
and finally an ideal solution should
have a low cost low development cost
without exposing the contact complex
details of the distributed systems and
networking
all of these requirements and
considerations are the motivation for us
to build Dental ml mental ml is an open
source framework for ML model serving
and deployment it offers
it offers a unified model API that
supports the most popular ml Frameworks
out of the box button ml also
standardizes deployment process through
the Bento artifact which you'll see
later allowing user to build once and
deploy everywhere in the most suitable
environment for the workload itself
since Pinto ml is python first it offers
native integration to all other
ecosystem Tooling in the ml space
so let's take a look at how banana does
it in detail
foreign
is a credit application service we saw
previously not implemented using Pinto
ml to evaluate the credit application
the service sorry let me look
so to evaluate the credit application
the service needs to undergo fraud
detection and risk assessment the fraud
detection step is based on a pi torch
model and the risk assessment step is
based on three different cycle learn
models once the fraud detection model
determines that the application is
genuine we will simultaneously assess
the risks from all three risk assessment
models and aggregate the results
together to form a decision
so let's break it down
first in this section of the code we
specify the Frameworks and models that
we need to create the runners runners in
Dental ml represent a unit of
computation that can be scaled
independently and there'll be this will
be a recurring theme in this case the
unit of computation is a model inference
next
we have we create a pental service named
credit application and pass the runners
that we created previously to the
service so later when we build the Bento
artifact the Builder would know the
structure of the service and the models
required
foreign
ly the apply API specifies the business
Logic the API declares that it takes and
Json input and Returns the Json output
beside Json the API can also support
tensors data frames and file types like
images it then fetches the feature from
an external feature store by supplying
the user ID it then passes the feature
together with the input data to the
fraud detection model render to get the
detection results
if the model dings the application is
not a fraud it will pass the application
data to all three risk assessment models
simultaneously aggregated assessments
and form a final decision
note that the model itself is a
self-contained
module and all the business logic lives
in the end to end it feels like writing
a single module Python program however
when it's deployed the service can be
flexibly deployed into multiple
different architectures that you can
choose the one that's best suited for
your use case
before we look into the deployed
architecture let's first look at the
building blocks of dental ml deployment
sorry
I'm missing a slide here but
so for the first uh type is uh an API
server an API server as a name suggests
is responsible for hosting the API
everything defined in the API function
call we saw previously runs in the API
server
it can include a custom business logic
such as pre-processing feature
transformation API or database calls it
can also include model monitoring logic
to detect potential data drifts or model
Decay it can also it's also a great
place to instrument observability
metrics though mental ml comes with
metrics for tracing and metrics and
tracing support out of the box user can
still instrument the custom metrics in
their API server
lastly the API server can call Runners
for model inference the inference can be
in done in parallel or in sequential our
previous example the three fraud
detection models will happen in parallel
without waiting for one another to
finish
so this is a
waterfall diagram to illustrate the
sequence of the calls as you can see the
fraud detection assessments happens in
parallel without waiting for one another
to finish
the second building block is a runner so
again runner in Dental ml represents a
unit of computation that can be scaled
independently mental ml provides a set
of built-in Runners for the most popular
enough Frameworks such as Pi torch
tensorflow Onyx with optimized runtimes
most importantly
most importantly Runners can perform
adaptive batching transparently to
improve inference efficiency as you
probably already know it is much more
efficient for Modern Hardware to process
multiple inferences in a batch than to
process them independently in a
individually in a sequence online
serving imposes a unique challenge to
batching because we do not control the
arrival time and rate of the requests
adaptive batching intelligently will
wait for some amount of time without
sacrificing performance and aggregate
all the inference requests arrived
during that period of time into a batch
and supply to the model as a result we
can significantly improve the model in
inference latency and throughput
lastly API server
communicates
communicates with Runners with a very
efficient RPC protocol to bring down the
inter-process communication overhead to
a minimum
so now that we understand the building
blocks let's look at two forms of the
most common deployment architecture
first one we see on the screen is the
container deployment once you have a
bentle you can run the pental unlock
container rights command to build an
image of your Bento that is Deployable
to any environment that supports
containers
an optimal number of API server and
Runners processes will be started from
within the container to work around the
python Global interpreter log to enter
maximize the throughput and utilization
of the available resources this approach
is simple and flexible for deploying to
any Cloud environment or on-prem
environment that supports containers
while container deployment is simple and
Powerful It suffers a same problem that
we mentioned earlier where the models
cannot be deployed and scaled
independently
to solve this limitation
let's look at the second
um let's look at the second deployment
architecture in Dental ml
so microservice architecture is came
into prominence thanks to its simple
Promises of having a single focus and
being able to scale independently
since annual Services typically come
with a wide range of workload types as
we mentioned previously from the compute
intensive model inference to i o
intensive feature transformation
the microservice architecture is
especially advantageous for ML Services
because they allow to parallelize the
workload to run on the most optimal
hardware and scale independently until
I'm not achieved this by offering the
Bento deployment custom resource
definition or crd in kubernetes served
by Cloud native components provided by
pental and now when a dental deployment
custom resource is created the cloud
native components will build the image
required and deployed API servers and
Runners as independently scaled pods
until I now respect the resource
requests and limits specified in the crd
and deploy only to nodes with those
types and quantity of resource available
for example if Nvidia GPU resources are
required requested until now will
automatically deploy the render pods on
the Node with Nvidia GPU device
any kubernetes deployment is not
complete without Auto scaling but time
now provides CPU and memory based Auto
scaling by default and we're actually
expanding that list
lastly all the dental deployment are
observable through grafana Stacks with
familiar tools for metrics logs and
traces
so to put it together we discussed two
groups of model serving Solutions the
off the shelf Solutions are optimal for
serving single models but becomes
inflexible as the use case becomes more
complex the in-house Solutions are
flexible to build custom business logic
and inference graphs but they come at a
very high engineering cost and time to
Market
an ideal solution as we described for
production skill model serving should
offer customizable business inference
business logic definition and inference
graphs and optimize runtime and Hardware
uh scheduling that allows independent
and automatic scaling of models
support for different deployment
environment without having user to
rewrite the service
and finally we walk through our journey
building Dental ML and how we strive to
make mental amount meeting this criteria
um thank you that is all of our talk
today uh if you're interested to learn
more please uh join our slack Community
for model serving to meet more ml
practitioners around the world
thank you
thank you very much
um we do have a question
so this is a question from Conrad would
you call Dental ml the cloud Foundry for
data science but uh controlling
everything within python code in a
single file
um I may not have understood that
analogy but uh the the philosophy behind
Bento ml is is that you can have a
single python definition that looks and
feels like you're just writing a program
that runs on a single node computer but
the uh the framework is capable of
transforming that python module into
something that's much more complex
that's much more sophisticated uh that's
uh you know without having to write all
the microservice specific code
interfacing with all the different
hardware and networking complexities so
if that's what you mean by being the
cloud Foundry for data science yes
that's the philosophy behind Bento ml
thanks for the question by the way
foreign
thank you thank you blue Tyson
also from Conrad Cloud Foundry uh uh
orchestration framework lets you plug in
AWS Azure div different things and
people use the cloud Foundry library to
control it
yes I think your previous analogy I
think fits the overall Dental philosophy
and also from Conrad curious what you
are using under the hood to set up all
the infrastructure how much of it is
python or something else so
um depends on the deployment environment
if it's kubernetes is done in goal
because it's most uh they integrates
with the kubernetes environment the best
but overall the philosophy is to
abstract that away from the user so they
don't have to see how it's done we're
working on Integrations with different
render environments that you know
see for example in uh
Onyx or Triton inference server that
could be done in total different
languages other than python so they can
perform model inference in a more
efficient way
but user does not have to interface with
that